this billion dollar company just went
bankrupt YouTubers claim to have lost
everything Mark Cuban was involved he
lost well he didn't lose everything
because he's a billionaire but he lost a
lot of money and so did his fans the
Mavericks who he sold this all to I'm
talking about Voyager why it matters and
why what they're doing right now might
be illegal so buckle up this is going to
be a long voyage
with over 2.7 million verified users
Voyager was an extremely popular crypto
broker to buy and sell crypto but even
more than that you could also earn money
on crypto you left with voyager up to
nine to ten percent now I can already
hear some of you saying that sounds
impossible it sounds like a Ponzi scheme
but like all Ponzi schemes this one was
different okay Voyager had a plan a plan
that couldn't possibly fail they told
users they were able to generate this
amazing yield because they took your
money and lint it out but not just to
anyone Voyager would only lend to the
most trustworthy people that's their
secret sauce according to their CEO so
you're minimizing the risk because of
who we're working with and they
advertise this a lot they claimed a low
risk approach to investing they said
that they could weather any bear Market
which is by the way a gigantic red flag
that you should never ignore but that
didn't stop popular crypto influencers
from hearing about it who began to
either promote it or put their own money
into this platform people like Scott
melker Andre dick Jeremy from Financial
education people you probably have
either never heard of or heard from way
too much such is the life of an Internet
celebrity but whether you've heard about
those guys or not the biggest name that
I know you will have heard of is Mark
Cuban who promoted this thing as well
and actually turned out to be the worst
of them all just listen to them pitch
Voyager as being as close to risk-free
as you can get in crypto I'm not trying
here to tell you it's 100 risk-free but
it's as close close to risk free as
you're going to get in the crypto
Universe Cuban said this as part of a
partnership with voyager where he sold
the Mavericks basically the entire city
of Dallas on what it was soon to be an
insolvent company but don't forget to
use the code math fans who download the
app
create an account using the promotional
code code Mavs 100 deposit one hundred
dollars and make a trade will get 100 in
crypto
it's all so pathetic isn't it to watch
billionaires sell to us like this the
pores I mean let's be perfectly clear
Mark Cuban is a terrible crypto investor
he's over two we've already covered his
last failed Venture anyways the point
I'm making though is that influencers
and celebrities were a huge part of
voyager's success and that makes sense
right because Financial disclosures from
Voyager show they were spending big on
marketing up to 80 million dollars a
year but all this hype quickly changed
when the news broke this past month
Voyager digital announcing today it's
the latest crypto firm to suspend
withdrawals deposits and trading
um as you're seeing there you know
basically lost everything in the stock
but I have a substantial amount of money
like multiple six figures that is locked
up to this day with voyager that I may
never get access to again most of my
ethereum is now temporarily we'll say I
don't know if I Voyager will make it
right gone my salon is gone so my
Bitcoin is gone and a lot of the things
that I got paid with in usdc go on right
man don't you feel bad for these
millionaires who put their money into
this risk-free investment well don't
feel too bad because according to some
of them they aren't actually victims
like I said I have been uh a victim I
guess we'll call it although I take full
responsibility for all of my own
decisions so none of us are really
victims right we knew the risks and we
took them that's Scott melker and yeah
he seems uh great after a lot of his
followers potentially lost all their
money he tells them that there's no such
thing as victims this is crypto brain
rot at its finest and it's also of
course happens to be wrong of course
because this idea that everyone
understood the risks is simply not true
as I'm going to demonstrate because
let's take a look at that how Voyager
collapsed to see what people actually
knew it turns out this news of Voyager
suspending withdrawals came right after
Stephen Ehrlich their CEO said that the
money was safe our customers assets are
safe and we're processing everything uh
as normal and Scott melker himself said
that he was shown evidence that the
money was fine get up their CFO they
showed me a whole lot of evidence that
things are fine that they are operating
in a completely different Manner and I
continue to hold my assets there of
course this all turned out to be a live
Voyager wasn't fine see it turns out
Voyager was actually insolvent because
one of the loans they had given out had
just gone bad but they didn't want to
scare anyone so they told people at the
last possible moment that they were
insolvent which brings us to their
second lie and misrepresentation which
is their marketing
they said that they had a low risk
approach to investing but actually it
turns out they actually gave 50 percent
of their loans or more to a single
person or hedge fund yeah that's what
diversification looks like these days
according to their documents Voyager
gave 654 million dollars of their loans
to a single hedge fund called three
arrows Capital now what did three arrows
Capital do with that money well they
invested it in Luna which after it
collapsed basically made this loan
worthless and this is where I realized
that Voyager was absolutely full of it
as were any influencers claiming that
everyone understood the risks this is
explicitly and provably false Voyager
lied and not just about the low risks it
turns out there was a lot more to this
story too see one of voyager's big
claims to fame was FDIC see insurance
for cash this is because they claim they
had a partnership with legitimate Bank
the Metropolitan Commercial Bank now the
reason they were able to claim this
apparently was because when you put your
money with voyager your cash they would
then put that money with the bank and
according to them and some magical
transitive property that they made up
the bank's FDIC insurance would cover
you even though you didn't put your
money technically with the bank you put
it with voyager but they said that FDIC
Insurance applied they even advertised
as much quote in the rare event due to
the company or our banking Partners
failure you are guaranteed a full
reimbursement the problem is though
that's not actually what they said in
their terms of service they said you
were only covered in the event of the
bank's failure not voyagers quote FDIC
insurance does not protect against the
failure of Voyager which is is a pretty
big difference especially when Voyager
failed and all those people who got in
thinking their USD was safe all of a
sudden realize that maybe it wasn't so
yeah that's a pretty massive lie and
probably is illegal although I have to
say I am not a lawyer although it is
being investigated as we speak by the
FDIC but speaking of lawyers this is
where things go absolutely bananas
because Voyager has obviously been
desperate to find a way out of this
situation and their latest attempt is
declaring chapter 11 bankruptcy which I
know you might think that means they're
going bust but it's not quite right see
bankruptcy isn't just one thing there's
many types which I know is a bit
confusing it's like hearing someone's a
doctor and then realizing it's not the
helpful kind it's the lecturing kind
anyways the point is there's many kinds
of bankruptcies just like there's many
kinds of doctors and they all do kind of
different things so to be clear chapter
11 is not where you sell everything in
close up shop it's special kind of
bankruptcy designed to let you
restructure your business to repay debts
meanwhile everything just kind of goes
on pause and Voyager loves this idea
because it lets them stay alive they
think they can restructure their way out
of insolvency by drumroll please
printing more money that's right they're
gonna print more Voyager bucks and
shares of Voyager now the problem with
this of course is what's the value of
coins and shares in a company that is
insolvent it's not very clear doesn't
seem very high so this seems like a
pretty Raw Deal for investors but a
bigger problem for Voyager is not that
it's that actually what they're doing
might not be illegal let me explain see
only certain types of companies are
eligible for a chapter 11 bankruptcy
when you go to file one of the first
things they ask is to describe the
debtor's business they list several
options like stock broker commodity
broker clearing bank but Voyager takes
none of these when they filled it out
they say it's none of the above in their
filing now this is pretty strange
because the CEO describes their business
as a brokerage they say this multiple
times so why does this even matter well
the reason they're asked earlier if
they're a stock broker or commodity
broker is because those companies
businesses aren't allowed to do a
chapter 11 bankruptcy instead they're
liquidated under a very special law
called sipa the Securities investors
protection act basically it's a law
designed for exactly this case when
brokerages go bust and it's good for the
investors because they get special
protections and are the first to get
paid according to axios reporting and
this is very different from regular
bankruptcies where investors can be the
absolute last to get paid so a sip of
liquidation could be good for investors
so why is Voyager not doing a sipa
liquidation well it seems like they're
trying to have their cake and eat it too
because on the one hand they claim to be
a brokerage but they're not filing
bankruptcy as a traditional brokerage
and instead are trying to file a Chapter
11 and I know it's getting complicated
but this is really important for the
investors the reason they're doing this
is because under a simple liquidation
even though customers might get a better
deal there's basically no chance a
voyager's plan to print more money and
stocks is Gonna Fly not only that
Voyager would probably have to cease
operations and so obviously Voyager
doesn't want that so instead they're
trying to claim that as a crypto broker
they're not selling securities or
anything that classifies as a stock or
commodity which is very gray regulatory
territory not only that they're claiming
that all their customers crypto is
actually their crypto and that their
customers are just unsecured creditors
so the customers don't actually own
anything and this is where I have to
tell you that this is pure lawyer Jiu
Jitsu they are trying to save voyager's
skin at the expense of their investors
because let's be clear Voyager was
absolutely happy to advertise things
like the easy way to build and track
your crypto portfolio but when push
comes to shove they say your crypto
portfolio doesn't actually belong to you
at all it actually means build voyager's
crypto portfolio because they're saying
they actually are the ones that own it
and if you're confused about out all
this how this advertising possibly makes
sense you're supposed to be it doesn't
make sense not only that voyager's own
app told people explicitly that they own
the crypto they bought thankfully in
their first bankruptcy hearing the judge
pointed this out and questioned whether
Voyager had even filed the right type of
bankruptcy case suggesting that it met
the criteria for liquidating as a quote
broker dealer with protected customer
accounts which obviously they want to
avoid for the reasons we just explained
this reporting comes from Reuters and I
think this judge is absolutely right in
what world would buying crypto be so
different from say buying a stock on
Robinhood it's regulatory mess sure but
customers deserve regulatory protection
and the only people who's arguing that
they don't is Voyager although their
lawyer a guy named sussberg says that
they're doing this for the good of the
customers actually see we have it all
twisted they claim that quote it would
result in a lot of expensive litigation
that would benefit no one now to be
honest I think sussberg is wrong here
and doesn't have their investors best
interests at heart because obviously he
works for Voyager not for the investors
and anytime someone is trying to tell
you that your money is not your money
and that they've already lied to you
about FDIC insurance and all these other
things I would be very skeptical if they
told you they're working in your best
interest instead it looks like Voyager
is acting in voyager's best interest but
I suppose the real question is what
happens now well it's actually not clear
the judge rightfully points out that the
case presents several novel legal
questions and I think part of that
outcome will be determined by what
voyager's customers want to do whether
they go along with voyager's plans or if
they raise concerns that maybe they
actually feel like they own Securities
and not just unsecured credit according
to a restructuring lawyer named Robert
honey Honeywell this could move their
claim higher up on the list because
owners of Securities are more protected
than just owners of random things but
with all this said and the outcome not
very clear
I feel like the lessons are actually
pretty clear influencers and celebrities
are bad and sad in this case because
they lost a lot of money investors are
screwed but maybe not completely
depending on how all this shakes out and
Voyager lied lied and lied some more
about the state of their finances and
risk and FDIC insurance and is now
trying to play some games with
bankruptcy law to save themselves and I
just can't help but thinking maybe there
are some victims here now will voyager's
plan work
I don't know but either way if you enjoy
High effort investigations like this
please pump the stock it really helps
and don't forget to use code MAV at
checkout code Mavs 100